hello and welcome to med simplified
chronic joint pain affects millions of
people across the world every year
thousands of patients routinely seek
medical attention for joint pain
and it is one of the leading causes of
disability to give you an estimate of
the disease
in 2002 about 10.5 million people in the
united states said
they experienced severe joint pain but
by 2014
that number had jumped to 14.6 million
that is according to the researchers
from the united states center of disease
control and prevention
severe joint pain can limit a person's
ability to perform basic functions
and seriously compromise the quality of
life joint pain in medical terms is
known as arthelasia
which is as common as a flu and can be
caused by a wide range of problems
such as bad posture overuse and misuse
of joints
like in case of athletes such as
footballers sprinters and tennis players
nutritional deficiencies in the diet
osteoarthritis
rheumatoid arthritis certain
neurological problems
kidney and liver problems just to name a
few
luckily with strict precautions good
exercise
proper diet and supplementation joint
pain can be managed
in this video we will discuss five of
the best foods that you should include
in your diet
if you are suffering from joint pain and
also the science behind it
make sure to subscribe to our channel as
we will soon be releasing many more
videos on the topic of joint health
also make sure to click the bell icon so
you get notified when we release these
videos
so without further ado let's begin and
the number one food that we have on our
list for people with chronic joint pain
is oily fish oily fish can reduce joint
pain and morning stiffness
as it contains unsaturated fats such as
ecosapentenoic acid
and docohexanoic acid which is epa and
dha
epa and dha also limit the production of
certain negative proteins
that inhibit certain types of arthritis
the omega-3 fatty acids present in fish
also increase blood flow throughout the
body during exercise
which can help reduce joint pain and
swelling it is recommended that each
person should consume at least two to
four weekly servings of fish like salmon
or sardines
it's hard for many people to consume
such quantities hence omega-3
fish or krill oil supplement can help
support joint health
i have put links to some of the best
fish oil supplements in the description
box down below
so you can check them out walnuts and
brazil nuts
like oily fish walnuts are a rich
vegetarian alternative source of
omega-3 fatty acids which reduces
inflammation
also eating walnuts regularly can lower
cholesterol
relax blood vessels to lessen stress on
the heart and reduce blood pressure
brazil nuts are high in selenium which
improves the quality of cartilage
proteins present in our bones and joints
snack on three or four each ray and you
should get all you require
selenium also helps to boost your
immunity which is very important
considering the pandemic
you can also watch our video on 10 best
foods to boost your immunity
by clicking the i button above
number third food that we have are dark
green leafy vegetables you might be
surprised but your mom was
right when she told you to eat broccoli
broccoli cauliflower
and cruciferous vegetables have shown to
protect against the development of
arthritis and joint pain
these also contain antioxidants like
carotenoids
which fight free radicals in the body
and prevent the damage to our cells and
tissues
not only do free radicals damage our
cells they also have been linked to
rheumatoid arthritis and inflammation
green leafy vegetables like broccoli
spinach brussel sprouts
kale swiss card and bok choy are packed
with antioxidants and vitamins
like vitamin a vitamin c and vitamin k
which protects the cells from free
radical damage
these foods are also high in bone
preserving calcium
onions and garlic onions
are a rich source of quercetin an
antioxidant that works to reduce
inflammation
red onions are particularly high in
these antioxidants
garlic contains allicin a compound that
can help to alleviate symptoms of
rheumatoid arthritis
garlic also contains dily disulfide
which is highly effective for body
and can help you with a number of
diseases including joint pain
the fifth and the last save of food that
you should include in your diet
is bone broth glucosamine chondritin
and amino acids are well documented to
help maintain healthy joints while
calcium is essential for bone density
bone broth contains all of them the
gelatin-like substance that comes from
cooking bones
mimics collagen that occurs naturally in
our joints
tendons and ligaments taken regularly as
an oral supplement
it has been shown to reduce joint pain
and
increase function for people with
arthritis taken regularly as an oral
supplement
it has been known to reduce joint pain
and increase function for people with
arthritis
so friends these were the five best
types of foods that you should include
in your diet
if you are constantly suffering from
joint pain and i have attached all the
relevant links for the supplements you
should consider taking
in the description box down below so you
can check them out
make sure to subscribe to our channel so
that you don't miss out on our upcoming
videos about joint health
where we will discuss about the
precautions you should take best types
of exercises for people with joint pain
and much more i hope you found this
video
helpful if you did make sure to hit the
like button below to support us
you can also support math simplified by
clicking the join button below
or joining our page at patreon.com thank
you so much for watching
see you in the next video